jonas is just looking up adjectives for
bad food
i think i'm gonna need them look at this
stuff we're gonna go to the store buy
some random stuff put it all into an
ai that generates recipes and we're
committing right now to cook
just move your hands in a kind of random
manner and
eat whatever it outputs
[Music]
all right everyone this is jonas he is
an expert in non-convex optimization
and also a very very good cook
it's going to be extra spicy for him
today when he has to follow instructions
by not-so-good cook which is the gpt-3
language model
yeah let's do it awesome
so here's the plan we're gonna go to the
store and each of us is just gonna buy
some
random items we don't know what the
other person is buying all right
what's real really weird
and we'll come back and whatever we have
we'll put into
gpt3 and ask us to generate a recipe for
it and we'll try to follow that recipe
as
closely as possible as closely as
possible as close as possible
and then whatever comes out yannick's
gonna eat it
and if it turns out great i'm gonna give
it a try as well no just kidding we're
both gonna eat it we're committing now
we're doing this
absolutely so there's a couple of rules
rule number one
jonas is a vegan which means that today
we're going full
co2 neutral absolutely organic
healthy 100 calories
ethically perfect vegan yeah
just yeah rule number two we're going to
follow the recipe
as closely as possible if it suggests an
ingredient that we happen to have
we're going to put it in if we need to
wait for a couple of hours come on who's
got time
but other than that we'll do whatever it
says there's lots of videos on how to do
bikey
probably they haven't done it yet on
minced meat and rule number three
we must finish our points are you ready
totally let's do it let's do it to the
kitchen to the kitchen
all right we are back from the store and
we got ourselves
a whole bunch of food is way too much
how's the experience
it was lovely so we went shopping and we
found
lots of tasty healthy vegan food items
i'm very sorry about that but that was
my restriction i'm sorry yannick so
today it's gonna be a vegan day
all right we got pretty normal stuff
this is an avocado
it's not just an avocado and it's
organic avocado well i have to check the
imprint
nice nice it's actually imprinted i've
never seen that
you should start doing that we got some
vegan
planter based butter
how ugly is that have you tried this
before yeah it's pretty good actually
tofu the classic the staple we also
have vegan plant-based what is this made
from
it's minced meat made of no cows
and no pork it's made of peas
probably other good stuff probably
tastes like pea too all right what else
we got we got
chocolate garlic sweet potatoes
mushrooms
okay man we have the super flavor here
jesus christ
if we're not going to be so hipster
after this yeah
we have these tasty goods how is this
it's not any chocolate it's a cooking
shot of course and we have
soy whipped cream
whipped cream okay it's beautiful all
right or just soy cream we're gonna put
all of this
into gt3 and whatever it spits out
we're gonna cook it and we're gonna eat
it
he's gonna eat it
jpt3 trained at openai
is a giant neural network called a
transformer
with over 175 billion parameters
it is trained as a language model which
means that if you give it a piece of
text
it can predict what the text will look
like that follows it it can do
so with remarkable accuracy and just
like a human would
can do it in multiple ways so you can
sample many times
given the same starting text and you
will receive many different answers
gpt3 can do this because it has been
trained
in a scrape of the entire internet in a
way it is the collective knowledge
of humankind at least what has been
written down in the internet
so let's see if we can make that
collective knowledge work
to generate one recipe
now remember that i said that you can
sample from the model and get multiple
answers we were a bit disingenuous here
in that we sampled a few times to make
sure that the recipe
was reasonably long and contained at
least some funny parts
though we genuinely were ready to accept
whatever came out as long as we could do
it
in a few hours so what we did here is we
input our list of ingredients and then
let the model generate the recipe
the model is usually pretty consistent
and outputs actually
regular recipes though i think the fact
that we sampled a few times
plus the fact that we gave it such a
weird combination of ingredients
made it a little bit thrown off okay
reduce the size of your prompt
we have too many ingredients money this
must be like dirty we don't have salt
and pepper right this is way too little
this is that's it this is too little the
other instructions are not
long enough i guess yeah serve the bread
with mustard and pomegranate
shred the carrots and grate the cheese
what cheese
still not as good not as good not as
good
so at the end we got a recipe that we
were reasonably satisfied with
and we went ahead and cooked
the recipe started out with us boiling
the potatoes and carrots
which was definitely a good surprise for
me
because i was worried as unboiled
potatoes aren't really something
nice to consume so at least gpt3 had the
foresight to boil
potatoes then step 2 in the meantime
prepare
the vegan minced meat or use pre-cooked
soy meat
jonas also enhanced our meat with some
very skilled shamanistic procedures
no hipster man the recipe went on asked
us to fry the butter
add the garlic computer science people
here's how you do garlic are you
how do you do garlic like smash
and stir for two minutes so far so good
we're gonna add soy cream stir and cook
for three minutes
okay this is the soy cream add it add it
come on it's all the way yeah three
minutes
oh next time you're set tell all your
vegan friends to
subscribe to yannick's channel this is
coming along nicely
step five add the pickles tomatoes and
beans
stir and simmer for another five minutes
so
the pickles are in there and it's
looking tasty this recipe wasn't so bad
until now we actually don't have pepper
this is already burning because
it's going absolutely great next comes
the bread
cut the bread in small squares and fry
in the vegan butter until golden brown
a chunk of butter that we're gonna put
into the pan
we decided to take a new pan for this
instead of
adding the bread to whatever we had
already see this this is the last thing
your arteries see
before they go okay we have to put the
bread now
you ready sure let's put the bread
next cut the limes into cubes and
squeeze the juice
into the bean mixture easier said than
done step eight
add the soy sauce parsley salt
pepper cumin cilantro
where did you come up with how did it
come up all right we're gonna leave that
away as per our rules if we don't have
it do you have cumin
no i don't know good and dried figs
in the meantime the bread's doing great
also the potatoes it's looking super
healthy
and the carrots the cherry should we
ever stop boiling the potatoes though it
doesn't say so
i think at some point we should stop
maybe later we didn't exactly have all
of that
but we made some substitutions i have
ketchup i mean we can totally get a
ketchup we're just going to
replace the cumin and the chilantro with
the coriander yeah
it's looking better and better actually
we totally need to figure out a name for
this recipe
the gpt toast or something like that add
the kale
kale cannot be unhealthy step 9 pour the
bean mix
into a blender the blender time
[Music]
this is where the recipe started to turn
a bit blending the bean mix was
definitely a first for me
but it was a lot of fun i have to admit
one spin it
but it sounds ready and whatever it's
gonna come together all in your stomach
anyway
so who cares step 10 bake for five
minutes in the oven
at 180 degrees celsius celsius that's
celsius for you americans
i think three blue one brown had a nice
mnemonic where you distribute 100
degrees celsius onto like a semicircle
so here you have this you have a
circle and then here is like 50 degrees
celsius
and here is 100 degrees celsius and here
is zero
and so if i want to like 60 degrees
celsius
then this angle right here i'll just
take this which is like 110
degrees so this is like 110 degrees i
add 32
and that gives me like so 142. so 60
degrees
celsius is like 140 too fahrenheit is
that correct
i don't know it doesn't fit
maybe we should first take it out but
she didn't say so it seemed a bit
pointless to bake something for five
minutes but we
trusted the recipe
step 11 cut the sweet potatoes in cubes
and add to a pot with the remaining
butter what
more butter come on i'm gonna have to do
100 workouts to compensate for this
what am i supposed to do with the carrot
does it say oh the carrot so the
carrot never ever
enters the recipe with the remaining
butter add the red beans mixture yeah
so the carrots just out of the game now
add the red beans
the most surprising part about this is
that this was probably the exact point
when the potatoes were
cooked the best so props to gpd3 for
timing us
so perfectly we then had to cut the bell
pepper into cubes
add to the pot and add the vegan minced
meat you can actually eat this raw
right you can but let's not do it all
right this is kind of sticky
minced meat is there what is this this
is the rest of the mince meat yeah we
didn't have enough butter
because you put all the butter in the
pot look the carrots
come on carrot you're part of the game
you're part of the team we need you
and cook everything in the oven at 180
degrees
for 10 minutes more once that came out
we added the avocado
chickpeas okay let's skip the chickpeas
let's skip the chickpeas
the chocolate and served
one bread with mustard and pomegranate
on top it might not be the most obvious
choice
but this was the ingredients that we
gave to gbt3 so you had to do something
with them and kudos to the model
that it waited until the very last
second until it added the ingredients
that it
really didn't want to add and i really
didn't want to eat
together at the end we got a nice warm
meal and we were absolutely thrilled to
see
what it would taste like
are you ready what part are you gonna
start with we committed
the sandwich with the chocolate and the
mustard on top i think i'll get myself a
nice
piece of chocolate bean lime
avocado carrot wait i'm
definitely definitely make sure to have
some of the pickles
fatty buttery bread nice
mustard and palm grenade kale
no not yet i need some of the minced
meat okay minced meat
and the chocolate do you have the
chocolate please do it chocolate let's
do the chocolate come on chocolate
thank you yeah enjoy
i like the chocolate part it's all
together
it's sweet and salty and bitter and sour
and buttery oh my god the sweet potatoes
i don't like the sour part of it that
must be the lemon like we have way too
much lemon in there like two entire
limes
[Music]
well he told us to and the pickle i mean
come on have you ever cooked
like fried a pickle before it's just
i'm actually surprised the sweet
potatoes are cooked through
when we had them in the in the pot for
like
an hour almost bill so grammar for that
i'm almost done yannick oh my god the
carrot
it wouldn't be the same without the
did this grow no i don't know
all right this is the last piece of not
fully chopped garlic
how do you like it excellent so this is
just the bread
i'm gonna eat some but i feel yeah i
think it's more like a low-carb guy
i feel we've fulfilled our duty it's
just the bread remaining and the rest
is done awesome excellent excellent
well thanks everyone for watching if you
have recipe ideas please don't send them
to us
yeah subscribe check out jonas's google
scholar
review his papers accept them strong
accept strong accept
smash accept and yeah bye-bye stay
healthy
don't eat vegan food don't eat vegan
[Applause]
cheap
[Music]
you